most people describe writing music as
possibly the hardest thing in the world
right you're sitting there you got the
pressure of a record company the
business pressure but also the creative
pressure and everything else that's on
you I mean that's that's a big part of
it for me I've found is that
um a lot of the time you get so in your
head about like writing songs and you
end up kind of as you're writing songs
you'll finish like a verse and be like
is this good right it's good enough and
you're like well you don't know you've
you know you've just started it but
um for me a big part of it is just kind
of
getting out of my own head and I feel
like whenever I'm trying to write good
music is usually when I write the worst
music or at least my least favorite
music when you come from a band like you
did there's a certain safety there right
because when you're with the band hey
you know you don't feel you feel
protected in a way so when you go solo
and you start writing it's a whole
different vibe right yeah I think it's
kind of like you know if there's a song
you don't like or something you don't
like in your head even if it's like a
subconscious thing you can kind of be
like
yeah well that wasn't really my choice
or you know that that kind of thing and
then yeah I mean it's definitely putting
obviously more of yourself out there
um but I kind of that's kind of what's
exciting when you were writing the new
album you said you were sitting and
listening a lot to Ram the Paul
McCartney yeah which is interesting to
me because that album Ram wasn't
considered like one of Paul's biggest or
the the bet but in with the sense of
History it's a [ __ ] great album right
Ram yeah so what happens you you listen
to that and is that is that what gets
you stoked you go I'm gonna make an
album as good as RAM I kept thinking
like oh I don't want to make fun music
and a lot of that was a subconscious
thing I just didn't really want to make
like the set I just didn't want to make
the same music that we're making the
band not because I didn't like it I just
didn't want I just wanted it to be a
different thing are you tortured in a
way because half of the world expects
you to make a fun light poppy record
they expect you to do something almost
you know trite right as long as it you
know appeals to young girls or something
and then the the artist in you was like
[ __ ] that
I'm a fan of McCartney I'm a fan of
Bowie I'm a fan of the stones I love
everything about that era and you want
to go in a different direction but then
you got everyone pulling at you and
telling you what to do to be
commercially successful you can almost
feel that torture I mean I got really
lucky first of all uh Rob Stringer who's
the head of Sony he signed me and he
signed us in the band as well so I've
been with them for a while but when I
signed
um on my own I kind of said I called him
and just said like I kind of need to go
and like figure this out a little bit
and I don't want
I really I'm not going to be able to do
it if you're like breathing down my neck
basically and
um and he was amazing about it he just
said like I want to hear it when you're
excited to play it to me so pretty go
and do your thing and and when you're
ready I'll hear it so he came when the
album was basically finished and I think
he was shooting himself quite a bit
because he shooting himself because he
had he hadn't he just hadn't heard
anything right the first time and I was
playing him like the finished album
right he said the first like four songs
he felt like he was drowning because he
just didn't know you know he didn't know
what he was expecting drowning in the
sense that he wasn't smelling the money
so scared he was just scared just he was
like I don't know what he's about to
play me I don't know what's about to
happen type thing and then he relaxed as
he listened yeah